he's been yemen's official president for
years but abdrabhuman surhadi has
largely stayed out of the public arena
that was until he made this announcement
on thursday
i announced the creation of a
presidential council that will carry out
the tasks during this transitional
period and i fully and irreversibly
delegate to the presidential leadership
council my full powers in accordance
with the constitution
many yemenis were never impressed by
hadi's leadership
he's not been a popular president
so he's been really quite difficult to
get out of power but i think that a lot
of things have happened recently in
international politics that have really
focused attention on needing to resolve
the yemen war the international
community would like something to happen
in yemen so that can it can consolidate
its bandwidth to focus on the war in
ukraine and also the humanitarian
disasters just gets worse and worse
the presidential council that will now
take over brings together most of the
country's opposition groups a united
front against the houthis the armed
group that has controlled much of
northern yemen for years
the council is headed by former minister
alimi who enjoys saudi support the
united arab emirates and saudi arabia
backed the move and pledged three
billion dollars of financial aid to
support the new leadership the fact that
the bulk both the saudis and the
iranians welcome the truce
simultaneously is a rare feat uh when it
comes to the yemen conflict and the fact
that uh you know both
or all the players all the stakeholders
are happy with this reconfiguration of
the government is very important it's
not clear however if the houthis will be
ready to make concessions or share power
with this new version of yemen's
unrecognized government
commenting via twitter rahudi spokesman
dismissed hadi's decision as a joke
saying that the future of yemen can be
decided only from within yemen the two
sides have agreed on a two-month
ceasefire that took effect on saturday
but the houthis still refused to attend
the negotiations in riyadh saying its
enemy territory and talks should be held
in a neutral location muhammad
al-jazeera